good morning Hank it's the day after you
got featured on YouTube good work in
honor of the recent video you made where
you told us 50 jokes in four minutes and
also in honor of my first book Looking
for Alaska which is about a kid who
memorizes the last words of famous
people today I'm going to share with you
the real last words of 50 famous and
deceased individuals Edgar George
Washington's last words were tis well
John Adams said Thomas Jefferson still
survives which curiously wasn't true
Jefferson had died earlier that same day
July 4th 1826 Jefferson's last words
were is it the fourth when Henrik
Ibsen's nurse said you seem to be
feeling much better today he said on the
contrary Winston Churchill said I'm
bored with it all the Roman Emperor
Vespasian's said woe is me I think I'm
becoming a god Nero said what an artist
the world is losing in me those Roman
emperors sure knew a thing or two about
humility when Lady Astor woke up from a
stupor to find everyone she knew in her
room she said am i dying or is this my
birthday it wasn't her birthday the poet
Dylan Thomas has last known words where
I've had 18 straight whiskeys I believe
that's the record Abraham Lincoln said
to his wife they won't think anything of
it just before John Wilkes Booth shot
and booths last words were useless
useless Henry Ward Beecher
now comes the mystery the Irish
playwright Brendan Behan turned to a nun
who is drawing his blood and said bless
you sister may all your sons be bishops
che guevara shoot coward you are only
going to kill a man Pancho Villa wasn't
quite so composed his last words were
don't let it end like this tell them I
said something Ben Franklin a dying man
can do nothing easy president Millard
Fillmore after a sip of porridge said
the nourishment is palatable FDR I have
a terrific headache robert e lee strike
the tenth Civil War Union General John
Sedgwick was staring across the
Confederate lines and he said they
couldn't hit an elephant at this dis
Confederate general Stonewall Jackson
said let us cross over the river and
rest under the shade of those trees
Charles Darwin said I am not in the
least afraid to die the Enlightenment
writer Voltaire when asked on his
deathbed to repudiate the devil said
this doesn't seem like a good time to be
making enemies Eugene O'Neill said I
knew it born in a hotel room and damn it
dying in a hotel room Elizabeth Barrett
Browning when asked how she was feeling
said beautiful Emily Dickinson said I
must go in the fog is rising the writer
Paul Claudel wasn't quite so
symbolically resonant his last words
were doctor do you think it was the
sausage oh Henry turn up the lights I
don't want to go home
the dark oscarwild dying in a garishly
decorated hotel room famously said
either that wallpaper goes or I do
Tolstoy said the truth is I care a great
deal how they and then died before
finishing the sentence the writer will
bethe vega told he was about to die said
all right then I'll say it Dante makes
me sick when John field was dying he was
asked whether he was a papist or a
Calvinist and he answered I'm a pianist
Queen Elizabeth all my possessions for a
moment in time WC Fields and I'm gonna
tone this down for any little
nerdfighter year said gosh darn the
whole frakkin world and everyone in it
but you Carlotta which sounds romantic
until you learned that his wife was
named Hattie Carlotta was his mistress
Franz Kafka beggin for morphine overdose
said kill me or else you are a murderer
after a doctor told him that the angels
were waiting for him relief and Allen
said waiting are they well let him wait
then he died Peter Pan author JM Barrie
said I can't sleep yes you can
Pablo Picasso drink to me Malcolm X this
is a house of peace when he was asked to
Pete any parting words of wisdom the
hotelier Conrad Hilton said leave the
shower curtain on the inside of the tub
which is good advice although in
retrospect I would have preferred it if
he said never let my granddaughter Paris
in front of a video camera the economist
John Maynard Keynes said I wish I'd
drunk more champagne the famous
Australian outlaw Ned Kelly pulled a
Vonnegut and said so it goes Edgar Allan
Poe Gord help my poor soul second city
founder Del Close said I'm tired of
being the funniest person in the room
Walt Whitman shift shift Thomas Edison
said it's very beautiful over there
George Bernard Shaw well it'll be a new
experience anyway HG Wells go away I'm
all right Daniel Webster I still live
and finally Beethoven friends applaud
the comedy is over Hank I'll see you
tomorrow